the whole Puerto Rico thing is is nuts
man I mean like all this stuff about
your dad
um I mean you talk about your dad with
like such reverence you know like you
really like like uh the way that he
pushed you and and how like you're
talking about your 9 10 years old and
your dad's like just pressuring you to
do like 13 stared handrails and like
then pressuring backside lip slide a 13
stair handle like yeah I mean that uh
it's just certain you know like I almost
have mixed feelings about that because
in words like the helmet coming off take
off your helmet do a 13 stair handrail
like in one sense it's so rad because he
made you into a beast yeah and in
another sense it's like whoa like you
were a little kid and he was like
pushing some pretty heavy stuff yeah
yeah no I mean I think of it the same
way it really is like a love hate thing
because
would I be the type of person and the
type of skateboarder and like have the
type of mindset that I do today if I
wasn't raised like that most likely not
but at the same time like it was [ __ ]
brutal like I I I'll always be thankful
for my dad being such a like supportive
dad on me as as being a skater it's like
for example he was a skater back in his
teenage years sure and obviously it was
at a way different point back in like
the 80s but like his parents were like
bro what the [ __ ] are you doing like go
to college or
do something with your life like why are
you playing with this toy and that's I'm
sure that's still a lot of parents these
days right so I'm thankful for that but
being that young and being pushed to do
the stuff that I did and like for
example like being at a big rail
like let's say we're like on a road trip
like an hour away from home we gotta
drive home after and
I'm just like [ __ ] like I I have to go
for it I'm like sitting there rolling up
to this rail for like an hour just
scared as [ __ ] but I'm just thinking
like I don't have an option because I'm
either gonna like send my body down this
rail and at least try to do it or he's
just gonna be pissed at me for like the
rest of the day so it's like [ __ ] every
time you went up to the rails you're
like hurry up hurry up or is he just
patient and waiting for you to not hurry
up but like he my dad carried this like
very like Stern strong demeanor and you
can just tell you can just tell by his
facial expression that you're just like
dude like you just you have to go for it
you know and you land it you look at
your dad and what does he do he's Juiced
he's probably proud he's proud yeah yeah
it's it's epic and uh but but even worse
but even more than that it's like like I
was saying he actually knew about
skating so it wasn't just like going to
a big rail and like grinding it he knew
that like all right like I've seen you
do like 50s feebles and stuff down other
bigger rails so you're at this 13 rail
like you gotta you gotta like backsmith
it or something you know yeah he really
like knew what I needed to do to like
have valid Clips in my video cards right
and he knew like what tricks had been
done on like every rail too dead it's
crazy
um man and so so then
he comes up with the idea that you're
gonna move to Puerto Rico and you're
kind of bummed because you're like whoa
I mean dude California is where it's at
what are we going to Puerto Rico for
yeah and uh and and that was because he
wanted to like have a huge weed growing
operation
that was part of it I think it was I
think it was like 50 50 like being being
that being one of the reasons and then
also just trying to keep me and my
siblings as secluded as possible from
normal lifestyle because I mean that's
the way rostas think about if you're
like a true Rasta
they think about normal society as just
like
the devil just kind of yeah yeah the
devil just a lot of like brainwashing
and you know that's why I never I never
you know ate normal food growing up
never ate fast food never like watch
normal movies never went to the movies
until I was 16 just not we didn't do
like normal life things and moving to an
island like that was just another step
into taking us
into keeping us under his wing and not
being a normal family normal kids were
you at least by the ocean in Puerto Rico
were you in the middle of Puerto Rico so
for a little bit we were in like a nice
gated community which was close to the
ocean and then we lived there for a year
and then after that the next couple the
next like two or three years that I was
there we were like in the [ __ ] jungle
for sure wow like up in the mountain was
like it was literally an hour drive up
the mountain from the nearest house so
do you have to like grow your own food
and grow your own weed and you do that I
mean we we did grow some stuff yeah he
had a big weed weed farm out there which
I don't even understand because I don't
think weed grows grows good in that
Humanity right I don't know I would
think that it was fantastic I'm pretty
sure it doesn't I think it's too wet and
I think it rains too much maybe it
doesn't like we grow pretty good in
Hawaii is like the same climate or no
not really no it's it's a little it's
not as hot there it's not as hot and
it's not as humid yeah okay yeah the
outdoor program I think it's tougher to
manage maybe but it's just risky yeah
with the weather and stuff because
before before going there like I was
I was raised around weed my whole life
like every house we lived in growing up
the biggest room in the house weed
plants everywhere wow like sometimes I
think you would literally be like his in
my mom's bed and then just like weed
plants just like hanging all over it
that's wild dude yeah so with the
mentality being to like
shelter you from like society and and
kind of keep you like out of all that
at the same time he's managing your
skate career so that's got to be like at
all like even for him like add-ons he
wants you to be blown up and and
successful and in the mix but he also
doesn't I know it's so weird bro these
are things like I haven't talked to him
in a lot of years now but these are the
type of things I wish I could just ask
him about because it really is confusing
like he wanted me to be this you know
big Superstar skateboarder but he wanted
it's like it's like he wanted to be he
he was a very controlling person
and he took it too far as to where like
he didn't know how to let me go on a
trip with my sponsors without him you
know he didn't know how to let me like
do anything without him being a part of
it and he filmed you like a ton in
Puerto Rico and the footage has never
went anywhere most of the footage yeah
is gone is it true that that uh it's a
lot of footage too yeah what was it a
kickflip backside lips slide down like a
gnarly yeah well sure yeah Wilshire 15 I
had the cover of skateboard mag and and
uh
dude I know so people speculate that you
didn't land that kickflip backside lip
down that handrail and you know for damn
sure you did and there's video of it but
yeah I know it's just lost the Lost
Tapes I mean yeah I landed it perfect
too it's so sick where are they do we
know he has them somewhere and he's in
Puerto Rico he would I I don't even know
where he's at right now but he would
never he would never give him back or I
wouldn't think so you know maybe if we
figure out how to rekindle our
relationship one day maybe we could
figure it out but like I don't know my
dad's a very uh
a very like strong like prideful person
you know he has a hard time like giving
up his pride and control on things so
he's not watching you on YouTube videos
because he probably doesn't have a
computer he's got to be like so proud of
you that's ridiculous like I I'm also
curious if he's like super heavy into
the roster lifestyle still I don't know
man have you tried to reach out at all
no it's been a while
I mean but that's almost something that
like you feel like you should do
10 years
it's been so long at this point you know
I assume that he's off like doing his
own thing and I'm sure he like has a new
family out there and stuff and I just
kind of I mean you speak about him
like I I just sense that there's so much
reverence so much respect when you speak
about it for sure yeah that uh he's got
to know that
you know you're not out there like bad
mouthing him like like you talk about
him like he's like this
you know like God to you like when you
were a kid yeah and um he's got to be so
proud of everything that you've
accomplished man yeah I mean I you know
I hope I hope he sees it that way I hope
he does I hope he sees this yeah and uh
you know like if if he were to reach out
to you I mean I guess he goes without
saying that your mom and and him aren't
in contact yeah
um yeah I don't think anyone's talked to
him for a while to be honest man but you
would be you would be open to it if he
did reach out to you I would be open to
it yeah dude epic it'd be good for the
soul yeah it's good like that's not even
closure but it's just kind of I mean
it's I think that it it would be
it seems it would be very healthy yeah
yeah actually my little brother is the
one that really wants to have a
relationship with him because he's the
most similar to my dad in that same way
where they just think about life and
just
the same way you know they just they
don't want to be a part of normal
society my little brother's like the
most chill he's actually a really sick
skater too sickest style but he's just
such like a chill just down to earth guy
just wants to like you know live on a
farm growing up grows on food and just
kick it so I'm more so wish that like
they had a relationship because I could
see like how it kind of affects his life
yeah with not having her having a
relationship with him but who knows
maybe one day we'll see how many
brothers do you have three brothers one
sister I'm the middle wow yeah it's no
secret that Johnny Knoxville and I are a
little older too old to deliver the mail
but we can still lick the stamp
and I think we look pretty good right
here this remains
remains were signed for selling
everybody grab these Johnny O
skateboards while you can I'd suggest
you hurry